bien
13 personas murieron que al intentar
escapar a una intervención policial en
una discoteca al norte del iba a pesar
de estar prohibidas las reuniones
sociales vecinos del lugar alertaron a
las autoridades sobre la realización de
la fiesta clandestina la policía
intervino local los asistentes en su
mayoría jóvenes trataron de escapar por
una puerta para no ser retenidos pero
esta puerta se convirtió en una trampa
porque se abre hacia dentro y al hacerlo
bloquearon la vía en la desesperación se
aglomeraron ejercieron presión entre
ellos algunos cayeron al suelo isaf
hicieron la policía detuvo a 22 jóvenes
las autoridades sanitarias les
practicaron una prueba de descarte del
cob en 1915 los intervenidos dieron
positivo al coronavirus el presidente de
martín vizcarra expresó su indignación y
exigió a la justicia una rigurosa
investigación y la máxima sanción para
los responsables que organizaron la
fiesta clandestina que reunió a 120
personas el mandatario señaló que el
esfuerzo de la lucha contra la pandemia
se puede ir por la borda si no se
obedecen las medidas sanitarias pero se
aproxima a los 600 mil contagiados
porque hoy 19 es el segundo país de
américa latina y el pse
en el mundo con más casos de coronavirus